mais fi omar à mes rivaux c'est ce que
j'appelle doit beaucoup d'humoristes
afrique et sont d'abord des comédiens
formé au théâtre quand tu me respectes
la mélodie entre entre les lignes ça
donne la beauté ça donc ça donc goût
entendre tu vois
[Musique]
aujourd'hui thérèse ndiaye fait la mise
en scène d'une pièce sur la polygamie un
de ses thèmes fétiches les gars si vous
êtes capable de prendre 2 4 femmes vous
ne pensez pas qu'on soit capable aussi
de prendre 2 4 hommes les femmes sont
encore rares dans le petit monde de
l'humour africains mais aux rencontres
internationales du rire à niamey et rue
leur propre soirée avec mes cheveux de
vrais les graisses
parce que les filles on se connaît tous
ici vous aimez toutes ressembler à des
vrais blanche et je vais partout où
garçons sont trop il va draguer pour moi
dans le rire au fait tous les messages
peuvent passer voilà quelle qu'en soit
la manière que tu donnes mais dans le
rire ça passe
thérèse souhaite que ses blagues fasse
rire y réfléchir
elle rêve de changer les mentalités qui
briment les femmes ainsi monologue choc
s'intitule excisées moins
je me souviens encore de cette alarme
[Musique]
de cette lame qui s'est approché de moi
le monologue dévoile beaucoup beaucoup
de mots qui sont dont les femmes sont
victimes au fait c'est à dire l'excision
lui même le mariage précoce la non
scolarisation de la jeune fille ou mais
j'ai l'impression que c'est un règlement
de compte nos sérieux c'est à dire je
suis passé par là ma fille passera par
là ma petite fille passera par là ainsi
depuis percé de fuite
pour moi c'est la lutte de changer un
peu la mentalité des gens au fait tu
vois la fuite à vis de l'excision
parce que les femmes en souffrent ça
l'était thérèse la seule femme
il me reste en guinée a été recruté par
le groupe les serial rieurs cofondée par
sow pedro qui l'a aidé à mettre en scène
son monologue sur l'excision le titre on
voulait que les gens attendent le moins
m
excision mercredi d'entendre excusez moi
et moi de parler excusez moi en guinée
ça veut dire excusez moi voilà non
excusées non si on parle de ses maximes
simple le truc la tournée du groupe en
région a soulevé la contreverse au point
où le spectacle s'est parfois fait sous
surveillance policière
c'était chaud c'était vraiment chaud
parler de l'axé lyon c'est au fait il
faut avoir du courage
combien ça coûte de ne plus rien sentir
lorsqu'on doit de ces me convient donc
vouloir parler de la de l'excision comme
ça devant eux c'était vraiment un gros
risque
mais heureusement que j'avais dégâts au
fait qui aimait pollet mais vous tenez à
le faire quand même mais oui pourquoi
parce que pour moi c'est entre eux il
faut qu'on en parle au fait ce voilà
quand est-ce que ça va s'arrêter comme
[Musique]
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas les
touareg nous emmène petits meubles peu
connu dans le monde
mais quand on fait du bruit min zhu fait
aussi de l'humour pour passer des
messages
combattre les divisions ethniques le
racisme des cieux touareg envers les
noirs
je revenais de l'école et que je t'ai
avec les personnes qui étaient noirs
mais anicet des problèmes en m'insulter
à la maison tu t'es pas vu comment tu
peux arrêter avec ce noir et tout est ce
problème de peau s'installe en prêteur
plus celui qui sont % touareg ou qui est
clair que l'autre quentin cameron est
drague ma chère tu veux tu veux pas tu
vas t d est désolé monsieur j'ai pas
votre temps et tu fais ça qui m'a bien
dit reviens ici toi monsieur jolie les
relations amoureuses 2000 l'humour
afrique chez les femmes humoristes c'est
aussi un combat contre les violences et
à ya beaucoup de viol aussi donc au
moins c'est un message de
sensibilisation qu'il faut qu'on arrête
ça quand la femme ne veut pas elle ne
veut pas on l'obligeait pas à ce que toi
tu as subi ça le mieux ou intégration
je dois le dire oui je les subis et pas
qu'une fois
c'est pas du tout facile de de vivre ça
et après de faire une nouvelle vie quoi
de construire une vie normale parce que
ça revienne toujours csn reviennent
toujours
mais c'est pas facile ça le gars
polygame il adore ça quand les femmes ne
s'entendent pas non pas du tout
diviser pour régner quoi parler de
polygamie à niamey ça va pas quand même
changé les veaux mère thérèse dit qu'il
est très difficile de changer les
mentalités
les élus croient quand je vois la fille
guinéenne qui vient des vallées donc ça
m'a beaucoup tourner le cerveau donc les
voies aux fêtes et les humoristes
ils sont à quelques pas nos enseignants
niveau de quelques fois les guérisseurs
on peut venir ici avec ses problèmes
avec tous en oublie on peut venir ici
avec des problèmes trouver des solutions
la polygamie tu es d'accord avec ça que
je suis pas sûr parce que chaque fois
qu'elle la prière et à problèmes
c'est ça parce que ça nous aide a évolué
cette comédie quelle façon quoi eh bien
ça nous a évolué sur le plan moral
aujourd'hui je fais d'humour d'abord
c'est pour dénoncer
je partage mes idées je je sensibilise
les gens et je mène un combat parce que
quand je dévoile les mots que
dont les femmes souffrent là j'essaie de
poser un peu le mal et tout quoi le
décret de ce soir vous savez c'est quoi
c'est la polyandrie est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec moi et ça va se faire
parce que cette femme venue à leur merci
c'était moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]